participation citoyenne et poésie
écriture littérature pourquoi ne pas
lier ces différents mondes on va en
parler avec cette nuit de l'écriture qui
va se dérouler à 50 ans en Yvelines
vendredi bonsoir Yvon de chant vous êtes
président du coeski et Jacques Fournier
directeur de la Maison de la poésie à
cours bonsoir un mot déjà peut-être pour
présenter ce codesquis c'est le conseil
en développement de 50 ans en Yvelines
vous réunissez associatif facteur
économique simple citoyen aussi et là
vous avez décidé de vous pencher sur 50
ans en Yvelines mais via l'écriture vous
invitez les gens à écrire c'est ça
pourquoi cette idée voilà tout à fait
alors nous avons l'habitude dans le
conseil de développement de de réfléchir
de façon un petit peu sérieuse quand
même il faut bien le dire sur les
différents sujets sur les grands projets
du territoire par exemple ou sur la vie
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc là on a
décidé de faire quelque chose de
différent d'une part de s'ouvrir à la
population à l'ensemble des 50 chinois
et puis d'autre part de le faire de
façon un petit peu plus ludique un peu
plus ouverte un peu plus poétique quoi
voilà donc c'est la première raison la
deuxième c'est que nous organisons une
tra également les rencontres entre les
élus du territoire et les membres du
codeski tous les ans et cette année nous
avons retenu le thème justement de la
démocratie participative aux côtés des
élus donc
c'est une bonne préparation mais déjà
sur cet aspect de la poésie ça veut dire
qu'il faut avoir une admiration une
affection particulière pour la poésie
pour venir participer alors absolument
pas parce que toute personne normalement
constituée est censé être déjà un
écrivain c'est-à-dire capable d'aligner
au moins deux mots donc à partir de là
on peut écrire même les personnes qui ne
savent pas écrire qui ne peuvent pas
écrire peuvent venir on les aidera vous
attendez tout le monde vous en attendez
quoi vous justement
c'est une très étroite collaboration
avec le codeski le montage de cette
soirée c'est c'est la preuve que la
poésie à sa place partout que les poètes
ont leur place partout
la poésie pour moi n'est pas un
amusement c'est d'abord quelques une
affaire très sérieuse après on en fait
ce qu'on veut se dire on
l'adapte et la poésie est quelque chose
qui justement est un véhicule qui permet
d'arriver à
à dire des choses donc c'est ce moyen là
qui m'intéresse après ce que j'en
attends c'est c'est une
c'est pour nous d'abord le le premier
atelier d'écriture de l'année de la
saison il y en aura d'autres il y en
aura beaucoup d'autres puisqu'il y a 4
weekends et une autre journée prévue en
mai
et on va voir un petit peu si on
accroche vraiment on a eu des demandes
autour des ateliers d'écriture là
l'intérêt c'était une sorte de
thématique bien particulière c'est à
dire que la poésie parle du réel parle
du concret et parler de la participation
citoyenne c'est bien cela c'est-à-dire
qu'on est vraiment dans une réalité
d'aujourd'hui les poètes ont des choses
à dire et je dirais que la poésie a des
choses à dire et on peut la dire après
la forme que prendront les écrits des
participants pour être très divers on
parle positif parce que ça se passe à la
Maison de la Poésie moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'écriture c'est
quelque chose de sérieux justement mais
peut-être que c'est trop sérieux aussi
cette soirée on garde le programme
quelques-unes des questions que vous
abordez c'est comme ça que la soirée est
vendue quelle place pour le citoyen dans
la décision publique à Valentin comment
faire entendre la voix des 5 continents
pour participer à la vie de la cité vous
n'avez pas peur que le public est et
peur de ces questions que vous posez et
que ce soit difficile d'approche vous
savez le public il s'intéresse à vos
projets d'abord dans sa famille ça sa
maison son appartement ensuite les
projets dans son quartier ou dans son
immeuble ou dans son bon les projets de
l'agglomération les projets de la
commune c'est la même chose les citoyens
sont intéressés à comment se décident en
fait l'évolution des réseaux de bus des
transports en commun pour aller à Paris
comment on développe le vivant ensemble
à 50 ans en Yvelines comment on aménage
le je sais pas moi le centre-ville par
exemple tout ça c'est des affaires de
citoyens
il y a pas besoin d'être un expert il
faut pas être un expert d'ailleurs il
faut être très simple citoyen un
habitant et ce sont des sujets qui sont
des sujets très simples et la question
est de savoir comment les gens se
s'approprient c'est investissent dans ce
type de questions est-ce qu'ils se
sentent suffisamment informés que de
quelle vie de quelle ville il rêve
en termes de relation avec les élus les
rêves cette ville est-ce qu'ils peuvent
imaginer qu'elle soit concrètes un jour
peut-être est-ce qu'il y aura une
restitution est-ce que ces écrits vont
être transmis aux élus ça va servir à
quelque chose alors nous avons d'une
part les personnes les participants qui
le souhaiteront
leur écrits qui seront édités sous une
forme qui leur sera ensuite distribué et
puis d'autre part nous allons
utiliser ces réflexions et ses
contributions pour préparer nous les
rencontres que nous avons avec les élus
du territoire début décembre et puis ça
restera festif juste très rapidement un
petit mot Jacques fourni il y aura des
animations organisées aussi par
déclicité à qui va participer voilà
d'abord il y aura deux écrivains
Noiret prix Apollinaire 2011 et Brigitte
Gires pris Charles Vildrac donc c'est
deux écrivains avec lesquels on a
l'habitude nous travaillé qui sont des
vrais animateurs d'ateliers d'écriture
des vrais écrivains ce qu'on cherche
aussi des gens très engagé dans ce qu'on
peut appeler la société et pour apporter
une sorte de respiration et un regard un
peu décalé on l'a demandé à Déclic
Théâtre de venir apporter des sortes de
de virgule
d'oralisation de mise en forme un peu
différente des consignes et des
résultats des consignes donc il y aura
pas pis et Séverine Adolf qui seront là
et on est très heureux de cette
collaboration de cette nouvelle
collaboration avec eux parce que on se
rappelait avec Papi que en 2004 on avait
déjà fait la même chose au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour une autre
nuit de l'écriture et on est très
content que tout cela puisse arriver
encore fois encore fondateur donc de
décliciter à travers de quoi qu'on
présente plus forcément merci à tous les
deux d'être venu nuit de l'écriture
Vendredi 19 Octobre 19h il reste
quelques places donc
n'hésitez pas à vous manifester